foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
call is free and some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it Joe is
in Houston to start off this particular
hour what's up Joe
hi Dave hi Jade it's a pleasure to speak
with you both you too sir how can we
help
yes sir so recently
um I I've heard you mentioned that you
don't advise someone to open a brokerage
account if their mortgage isn't paid off
and I've been listening to you for a
little while now and my question is I'm
on baby step four five and six and I'm
trying to invest 15 of my income and I'm
maxing out my 401k at my work I'm also
maxing out uh Roth IRA for my myself and
my wife so my question is what's the
extra percentages I have do I open a
brokerage account and just put them in
mutual funds or should I just fill the
rest of my mortgage you can just throw
you're not up to 15 by doing all of that
no sir because our our incomes
approaching about 300K way to go
congratulations okay well then yeah I
mean you just need to get it into mutual
funds if you want to use a brokerage
account to put it into mutual funds
that's fine uh the thing when most
people say brokerage account they mean
I'm going to take my golfing buddies
best suggestion and buy some stocks with
some broker
right translation you're getting ready
to lose your freaking money
okay and so but you actually tactically
functionally can use a brokerage account
to buy mutual funds if you get with one
of our smart investor Pros you'll just
have an account with them that they
manage everything and you can put like
your smart you can put your Roth IRAs in
that account you can put your other
stuff in that account and it is it does
technically fall under the heading of a
brokerage account but this is not a
count an account where we're buying and
selling single stocks and sometimes
people translate the word brokerage
account to that
when I hear someone say that off the
street that's what I always think
they're talking about because it usually
is you see what I'm saying
right would you recommend putting in the
four types of mutual funds that you
particularly recommend or or an index
fund uh since it's taxable probably an
index fund probably putting a five s p
500 because it's gonna that is it that
falls in the growth in growth stock
category but it's going to have a low
turnover ratio so you're not going to be
taxes on it until you cash it out right
to amount anything
all right well I appreciate it thank you
yeah I'll go is there another way to Max
that you don't have any self-employed
income of any kind
no sir okay I don't know of another way
to Max that out but again if you're
working with smartmister Pro you might
ask them if there's another way to get
at that well the good thing is he's got
a high income I bet
I bet he to retire a little earlier than
average and then he'll have some money
available to him before 59 and a half
yeah that s p will serve you're right
there's a bridge yeah there's some
Bridge money because you're putting 45
000 bucks away yeah 15 of 300 000 and
he's putting you know 45 Grand away a
year that's four grand a month I mean
he's kicking butt he's doing great
that's going to get him to some serious
net worth very very quickly wow I love
it
there's just people all over America
that have a brain none of them are in
Washington DC but there's people all
over America that have a brain that
guy's got a brain he sure does that's
just incredible yeah I like how he's I
like what he's doing they're everywhere
they're smart people they're really are
smart people out there you just don't
see them much on the news
Arnold's with us in Houston Texas Hey
Arnold what's up
Arnold
Uh something's wrong with your phone try
one more time take it off speakerphone
three
okay you got to get you're gonna have to
get back on and see if we can teach you
to use your phone all right Stephen Is
With Us in Springfield Missouri Hey
Stephen what's up
hey Dave thanks for taking my call can
you hear me okay sure what's up hey Dave
uh my wife and I we have a primary
residence that's on a 15-year loan we
owe about 220 000. but we own a lake
property that we we paid off actually
down near Branston
um it's on a one-year lease right now
it'll be up soon we're contemplating uh
it's worth about 350 000. we've thought
about just selling it to pay off the
primary kind of we've done a little bit
of Davis over the years we've flipped a
couple properties but we have five kids
um and we could we could sell the lake
house for about 350 000 and pay off the
current so just kind of want to get your
thoughts on on what you would do in that
situation what's your income
I'm in sales uh base is around 140 but
uh goes up to about 175 if I have a good
year my wife stays at home with our kids
do you love do you have any other debt
it's just those two homes right or it's
just the one yeah
yeah just the just the dead on the
primary residence no other personal debt
so your leased your lease your lake
house out because you're not using it
yeah we bought it to use you know go
down to the lake and use it from time to
time and and then we just we don't get
down enough with the kids being so busy
so we and it generates paid off but uh
we get 2200 a month uh well twenty three
hundred dollars a month but we still pay
the HOAs so we net about 2 000 a month
so emotionally this is not your family's
favorite place to go in the summer that
you're going to sell and your children
are all going to run away and hide in a
homeless shelter because they hate their
dad emotionally this is a rental house
yeah I mean I'm from the area so there
is there is some connection to the area
but uh if I sold my lake house
um I you will probably never find my
body
my children and my grandchildren would
go bananas we're there every weekend all
summer boats and Sea-Doos and skis and
tubes and if I sold my lake house it
would be like the end of the Ramsey
family as we know it and so you're not
even in that category is it far from you
is it a far driver no we're two hours
away we're out near Joplin but like I
said with the kids being busy in school
we just don't get down there as much and
so I've done some math and I'm like you
know if we go down and run an Airbnb 15
nights a year go see my family you know
it the the utility these utilities are
the property tax and HOA and the
insurance I mean let's say it's five
grand a year you don't want the house
anymore sell it
[Laughter]
16 times in this conversation yeah
there was no fight in you at all to keep
it I gave you every chance how does your
wife feel is she ready to get rid of it
yeah I think so yeah
salad yeah
if your wife says sell it sell it she's
right is it that you're just having a
hard time because it's cash flowing
yeah you feel like you're uh look yeah
and we're just like well we have one
house paid off but not the primary so we
can go back and forth in our minds I
think we're trading if you were gonna
buy a 300 000 rental it would not be a
lake house two hours away
right this became a rental by default
when your family quit using it
right Charlotte
fair enough thanks no default no default
rental properties well that's exciting
he's getting ready to have a paid off
primary mortgage with five kids five
kids wonderful telling you Jade they're
smart people smart people we met a
couple of them today we are collecting
them here on the Ramsay show we have the
largest collection of smart people I
Love It in America watch the other shows
they're not on those shows
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us America
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five today's question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
when something in your home breaks
neighborly is the name to remember you
know it by names like Mr Rooter or Molly
Maid or Mr Electric and many many other
wonderful names and the neighborly Done
Right promise with that you'll know
you're getting great service from their
network of local
home service providers it's incredible
company we are honored to have them
sponsoring our question of the day so go
to neighborly.com today today's question
of the day comes from Andrew in
Wisconsin he says I'm in my mid-50s with
two kids I've done relatively well in
life but have had some problems in life
like cancer I recovered thankfully but
it does run in my family so I'm worried
about how long I'll live and I wrote a
will last year I have a son and daughter
in their 20s one is doing well the other
not so much my youngest daughter has
struggled with addiction to opiates and
has gone to rehab several times although
she has been sober now for several
months I'm well aware of the idea that
once an addict always an addict how
should I set up my will so that I keep
my daughter safe when I pass my friend
suggested that I request it gets paid in
annuity as opposed to a lump sum I'm
looking for your advice on this that's a
really really good question well I'm
glad that you're doing well from the
cancer
um you know I would suggest I think it's
a great thing that you have a will but I
would suggest also uh getting a trust in
place and I'm telling you that because
it's going to allow you to determine how
this money is distributed and all the
different terms around it my husband and
I are actually walking through that with
our trust and with our kids
um oh will is a great place to start but
if you if you have those things that you
want to delineate with your children
you're going to have to take it a step
further
um and get a trust and so that's what I
would suggest to you
um and just put in there whatever you
wanted Dave I know you've got a whole
lot of stipulations on how these things
work out especially when it comes to to
addicts you know you gotta you gotta be
careful there yeah your your friend is
wrong an annuity won't work that will be
a steady stream of payments to buy
opiates with
you know anybody doesn't turn on or off
based on her addiction right and so
um you can um you can set a trustee on a
trust and the trust can be formed at
your death at the direction of the will
you don't have to put it in place now
and her portion your son's portion could
be just released to him her portion
could be left into trust and
um you know I I would release amounts of
money based on uh years or months of
sobriety
because what we're trying to do here is
not Finance
her addiction
and um and and not jar her and knock her
out of the saddle of sobriety so I mean
let's just pretend okay let's just throw
out and a number that to her is Big
whatever that number is could knock her
out of the saddle
because she has a sense that now she has
a new source of uh of uh of provision
for her whole life and so she relaxes a
little bit in the in the fight to stay
sober
and so uh if she perceives a hundred
thousand dollars to be a lot of money
it's not in these situations but if she
perceives that it could knock her out of
the saddle so I would personally leave
it into a trust and get with an estate
planning attorney and um have the
trustee uh monitor her sobriety and if
she's attending AAA for instance uh you
would get a coin at various milestones
and based on those Milestones you could
release money
uh at the one year you know she's
already been sober for a while it sounds
like that's good several months um and
but I mean I had a one year mark a
two-year Mark a five-year Mark
um or you could increase it or you could
release it all at a certain Mark if
someone's been sober for five or ten
years that you know they've done
especially from opioids that you know
I'm not an addiction expert but sadly we
work with a lot of addicts so we've
learned a lot because 100 of addicts
have money problems
stuff's expensive and so um uh yeah uh
anyway we get to learn a lot about it
sadly and um as a Layman not as a
medical professional but anyway all that
to say opiates if she can stay dry five
years she's probably dry for Life yeah
and um he's in his mid 50s you're you're
gonna God willing be able to
watch this yeah throughout the next 10
years and make those adjustments you
could just do away with the trust at
some point like if in other words if
let's say you live 10 years and she's
dry for 10 years you could say all right
I don't need the trust and redo your
will yeah yeah but um but in in the
meantime uh if you're going to do it
today I would just say okay give some
milestones and you could work with her
counselor you could have the counselor
report to the trustee
uh and they have to have the she has to
sign the right to do that in order to
get money because counselor cannot
report her information legally without
her permission but she could say okay in
order to get you know funds released the
counselor has to the sponsor from AAA
has to whatever it is and then the
trustee whoever this I would not make
your son the trustee I don't want him to
be his his sister's keeper that's a good
point I want him to just be able to love
her as and support her as her brother
well not the keeper of her money and you
should have these discussions with both
of them yeah talk about it yeah talk
about it that's a really good point
anytime you're dealing with adults and a
will of any kind just say look if you're
going to piss people off do it while
you're alive okay tell them you're not
in the will you're not in the will okay
yeah it's not fair for everybody else to
have to deal with your actions after
you're gone and everybody else is
emotional about it so you need to have a
reading of the will or essentially that
where everybody knows what's going on
here and you know and it's real easy
with or I'm just going to say I love you
so much that I'm not going to finance a
potential relapse absolutely and so I'm
going to Dole this out based on sobriety
because as an act of love not as an act
of punishment for jurisdiction and talk
to her about that while you're alive
because trusts can't convey the emotion
of a dad right he's loving his daughter
well right and so
that this is an excellent time to do
that so it's a really good point Jade
and just a reminder everybody needs a
will yep right everybody needs a will
everybody doesn't need a trust but there
are times when
um it's the best choice for you yeah and
the only time you're going to have
ongoing trusts
um typically are special needs child is
going to be ongoing throughout their
life a situation like this is going to
be ongoing but it's probably not forever
it's not Perpetual right uh the only and
the only other ongoing truster where
there's like large
a larger state where you're trying to
manage the estate out of trust not just
not just keep from harming someone that
you're leaving behind right like your
children if you've got minor children
then none of them are special needs you
you might just have a trust that until
they're a certain age and then it
evaporates and the money's just
distributed to them and that would be
normal as well so uh fun stuff fun stuff
yeah go to mama bearlegalforms.com if
you don't have your will in place and
they can help you with basic trusts as
well if you need a complicated thing
like this one's a little complicated I'd
probably see an estate planning attorney
it's worth a few hundred dollars to uh
more to to get this done right and to
have someone that teaches you and
consults with you about what the law
allows in your state on managing that
distribution but the annuity is not the
answer Arnold is with us in Houston
Texas hi and Arnold welcome to the
Ramsey show did we get your phone fixed
brother
yes sir how you doing Mr Ramsey better
than I deserve that is so much better
thank you sir how can I help
uh just uh well I've been uh I've been
following the show for about a year now
and finally decided to start doing
things uh the way you teach and well I
got a little bit of a question I'm about
to start this that snowball and I want
to know if it's a little bit different
in my case uh so I have a motorcycle
loan got my ex-girlfriend took out for
me
um I crashed the motorcycle and I
injured myself pretty badly after a
couple of months with litigation I got a
settlement that's just enough to cover
the loan about fifteen thousand dollars
um so what I'm wondering is do I dump
that into this that snowball or do I pay
off do I pay her off so she can uh you
know be out of my life for good and I
can be out of first you pay her off
I pair off yeah sure right that's the
right thing to do you need to it's not
fair to her
yeah this whole movie this whole move
was dumb on her part your part and
because and you can tell why now because
it's left you in a Lurch emotionally and
relationally and so and this money was
for the motorcycle from the motorcycle
about the motorcycle so you just pay her
off and that's clear as it so it's not
it's not a random piece of money right
yeah
I would do the same thing get her out of
your life if you you use those words get
her out of my life yeah and my guess is
she feels the same way yeah this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you are a new
listener or viewer and we know there are
a bunch of you based on all of our
analytics and numbers and a huge number
of you have joined us in just the last
few months thank you for that uh you may
be a little bit out of the loop on all
these all this lingo the baby steps and
debt snowballs and all those kinds of
things we talk about around here all the
time we'll try to keep you up to date
but if you want to really dive into it
and start to learn where you are and
where you need to go next uh it's a free
service just go to ramsesolutions.com
click on get started and I will help you
figure out your next best step from
where you are right now
ramseysolutions.com it's completely free
click get started Sandy is with us in
Nashville hi Sandy welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
um I've been agonizing over something
for a few weeks walking around my house
saying what would Dave say what would
Dave say so today I decided to call and
see what you would say about this my
husband wants to buy an Airbnb in
Florida as an investment we have no
emergency fund we have excellent credit
all we do have is the equity in our
house which we do have a mortgage on
um I'm terrified about this idea it
would require a home equity line of
credit and possibly another investment
mortgage loan on top of that
so what you already know what Dave would
say
yes I do I believe and do you want to
know what Jade would say
yes yes yes well I might not be able to
say on the air but
but
it ends in the word no
yeah Capital you know you're broke
people broke people don't need to buy
investment properties broke people
really don't need to buy high risk
really don't need to buy high-risk
investment properties in another state
with all 100 percent borrowed money
leveraged on your own home
go sideways it's got nowhere to go but
bad
okay so let me let me tell you he's been
watching he's been spending too much
time on the internet
yeah so here's what the internet here's
what the idiots on Tic Tac will tell you
okay
that um that running an Airbnb is a
hundred percent profit you're going to
make so much money you're going to be
just bathing in money there's going to
be cash everywhere it fails to mention
that renters that tear up your house it
fails to mention the times that it sits
empty it fails to mention the high
management fees it fails to mention all
of the costs of your maid service it
fails to mention uh the fact that the
local municipality decides that airbnbs
are no longer legal and they pass a law
prohibiting Airbnb in your neighborhood
which is happening in some areas and
HOAs are preventing them left and right
because they don't want a hotel in their
neighborhood which is essentially what a
Airbnb is and uh the things if
everything works perfect the way the Tic
Tac guys say you're going to be so rich
it's unbelievable but guess what you and
I live in the real world it doesn't work
that way running an Airbnb is a complete
pain in the bahunkas
okay
okay that's exactly what every cell in
me is screaming yeah are you going to be
able to convince him of that she's not
going to sign the deed
I'm praying I'm praying so just know I
refuse to sign the HELOC
the house has your name on it in
Tennessee as well he can't get a HELOC
without your signature
right no okay well I uh
we'll discuss the marriage aspects of
this but no
thank you all right yeah don't do it
because well you know here's the thing
who can find a virtuous wife for her
worth is far above rubies the heart of
her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain
Sandy you have what's called common
sense
you can perceive risk a mile away your
husband has spent so much time on Tic
Tac that he has no idea what real risk
is and how much work and Hassle and
problems this is you can make money
running an Airbnb but you know you can
also make money running a hotel but it's
called a full-time job
somebody has to manage the hotel
somebody has to manage the maintenance
people somebody has to manage the maid
service somebody has to this is not just
found money that you walk out on the
sidewalk and pick up a bail of money
because you signed up for Airbnb because
some on Tic Tac said it was a
great idea it's passive it's passive
income there's no passive about it you
talk about active this is about as
active a piece of real estate as you can
get
again there is situations where you can
make Bank on this if you're willing to
go through the hassle and the hard work
and put up with it but it's not as much
as people say it is and it's certainly
not as much as your gross rent
projection is by freaking Airbnb because
all they'll tell you is you keep it full
all the time here's what we can get for
it well nobody keeps it full all the
time
number one number two nobody puts
everybody in there and 100 of them pay
never happens nobody puts everybody in
there and they don't tear it up past the
beyond the level of their deposit never
happens so dad gum man I got a a
Three Degrees of Separation uh-huh guy
that has a an expensive property that he
put and uh a bunch of
uh uh
characters
went in there and one of them killed the
other one in his house
that's my that's my love of Airbnb it
just went away right then but that
doesn't happen very often but I mean
these characters and this was not a
cheap this was not a house in the yeah
in the wrong end of town or whatever it
is you know
sheesh no this is this was people
partying and they party too hard oh my
gosh yeah out of control
so yeah it's uh you know it does that is
that is that gonna happen no that's not
gonna happen right all right but the
point is you're running a high turnover
night tonight week to week rental if
this is not you put a tenant in there
and they stay in there a year and you
have a an actual relationship with a
tenant so okay so here I am playing
Devil's Advocate as I sometimes do there
are listeners who want to get into that
space and they they don't we don't want
them to listen to Tic Tac as you call it
what do you say to the person pay cash
for it after your home's paid for baby
step seven and understand that you are
embracing two things that no one talks
about when you do Airbnb High hassle
Factor high risk
yeah and so you have to apply those to
the numbers it's the same thing when
some somebody goes to one of these
nothing down real estate crap and they
go I can rent the house for a thousand
dollars and my payment's only 500 I'm in
a cash flow 500. well let me let me tell
you how that works in the end okay if
that's the case you're going to break
even uh-huh with vacancy
with non-payment with suing to a victim
with fixing the repairs beyond the
deposits with fixing the repairs that
just happened to a house the heat and
air goes out the roof leaks paying the
insurance paying the taxes messing with
it
you you got a 500 cash flow no you don't
you're breaking even this is what people
don't grasp well I have a 500 cash flow
what that means is you don't know what
the flip you're doing you have no
knowledge of how real estate really
works my homes and properties of all
kinds are 100 paid for and I swear I
wonder if some of them are going to cash
flow then wow you know I mean it's
unbelievable and you do no you do no
Airbnb and wouldn't even get into it no
no Winston Cruz runs all that stuff
Rachel's husband he would shoot me if I
propose Airbnb it would make his life
miserable and but why is that miserable
well yeah versus the risk it's not worth
the risk the juice ain't worth the
squeeze there you go that's what I want
people to get like just pay cash for a
normal rental right yeah that's what I
want why even if you want to do it you
probably could make more money mm-hmm
net net you would make more money if you
could get it if you have a reasonable
property you'll make more money doing an
Airbnb than you would on than you would
rent it out but not just some guy off
the streets who thinks they're just
gonna yeah net net you would do that but
even if you don't know what you're doing
and you don't know if you're how to be a
landlord net you'd make more money but
you what you need to perceive is the
extra hassle level it is real you're
dealing with a lot of human beings
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America speaking of co-host Ken Coleman
is has launched an exciting new event
where we have launched an exciting new
event with Ken Coleman called Career
breakthrough whether you feel stuck in
your current job because of fear and
doubt or you have an idea you want to
pursue but you don't know how to get
there or you just need someone to tell
you you can do it you need to come to
this Ken Coleman is the guy and at his
event career breakthrough is just for
you you can join Ken live in person this
spring for an event that will give you
Clarity confidence and courage to do the
work you were born to do Ken's going to
take questions interact with the
audience
and talk to you guys and every ticket
comes with his get to clear assessment
as well uh the career breakthrough is
going to be Kansas City Missouri April
20 coming up quick here Chicago Illinois
May 16 Atlanta Georgia May 18 and Dallas
Texas May 23rd tickets start at just
fifty dollars these are small events
only gonna be three or four hundred
people so if you want an intimate
interaction with Ken and an audience to
be able to get questions answered and
actually take you where you need to go
get signed up for these just go to
ramseysolutions.com
events Al is with us in Bethesda hey Al
welcome to the Ramsey Show
oh yeah thank you good afternoon thanks
for having me on certainly how can we
help
yeah my question is how would you advise
my wife and I to determine the best high
growth industries when considering a
career change
um
well high growth is a good thing to look
at
I also would look at how you're wired
and what's going to make you smile
I don't care if it's high growth if you
hate it every single day
there's not enough money on the planet
to make you happy then
no that definitely makes sense I I am
actually reading Ken Coleman's book from
Payton Texas to purpose good
um but we're yeah we're just really just
trying to get all avenues and
information to talk to different people
about different careers what we could do
she's a CPA and I do research for the
Department of Defense and we've both
been working
about 12 to 13 14 years something like
that so and uh I we just both have
realization being in middle management
that is wow the folks in upper
management are the students like they do
have the burden of responsibility and
Leadership but certainly
it feels like we're working more than
perhaps they are so we're just kind of
looking at each other we're both 33 and
saying like are we really going to do
this for the next 20 to 30 here so
have you done the career assessment that
Ken offers to see where you're what
you're wired to do I have not where
where is that where is that assessment
like if you don't mind you can you can
go to his uh website and find it when
you find it in the Ramsey solutions
store ramsaysolutions.com we'll give you
a couple of them uh so you guys can take
it and that'll be helpful
um I think one of the things you're
going to find out is that you're both
detail people right
yes very much so and I'm not so if you
put me into a detail thing it would be
like uh as a friend of mine says
leukemia to my soul you know but yeah no
thank you if I had to do what your wife
does every day I would you know I I want
to read the reports that she does but I
don't want to create them you know so uh
from a CPA perspective now here's the
thing it might be that being a CPA is
not a problem it might be how she's
doing it maybe start your own practice
where the sky's the limit
and then do the same work but for
yourself and make a lot more money maybe
that's maybe it's that simple uh in your
case research is not something you
necessarily start up on your own maybe
it is I don't know what field you're in
but um
but whatever you move towards needs to
have lots of detail like for instance
I'm not going to recommend and it's not
necessarily well it is actually probably
a pretty growth oriented thing right
this second
um is event planner okay where it's
different every day it's constant change
uh there's a lot of uh a lot of human
beings running around with drama trying
to get the event off the ground whether
it's the Crew putting in the the sound
system or the the the the people running
the Event Center or the client then
you're not doing that one okay that one
don't fit you okay it would be you'd be
miserable for you so you know you're
going to find those things out from this
career assessment but then I it can be
that what you described to me was not
necessarily a career path problem it was
the where you're doing it is the problem
yeah I think you might be onto something
there
so yeah yeah I will give you that you
guys take that but then I would look
around and go okay
um
you know technology is is obviously
anything that falls under that bucket
and that's a really large bucket
uh you know a guy like you if you want
to learn programming or you want to get
into that field uh there's a lot of
stuff that's booming there uh any
anything around that
word assuming you develop some skills in
that area uh which you could do pretty
quickly with your natural bent is my
guess you might go to code School you
might do something else you might study
security
uh you know digital security
applications and uh just a huge huge
booming it's a gold gold mine gold rush
right now uh but you know it doesn't
necessarily mean that's for you but I
would not pick it based you know you're
reading that from Ken already I would
not pick it based on only on
um
you know what's booming yeah and what
you can make money with no I don't want
to go to a dentist
that chose being a dentist because
there's a lot of money in it exactly I
they
um
and I they don't they don't I want to go
to a dentist that shows it as an
opportunity to serve in the Medical Arts
and they're a compassionate person
because I'm a coward oh yeah well we've
all we've all dealt with people who it's
like wow you you need to go on and do
something that gives you some Joy
we've all encountered those people where
it's like why are you doing this every
day you're clearly miserable is it just
for the paycheck I mean you don't
definitely don't want to be one of those
people
um yeah that would be as you say the
tail wagging the dog so
John Is With Us in Modesto California hi
John how are you
good thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
so um we took out a HELOC last year uh
to make some upgrades around the house
and also to put a practice baseball
field in our backyard
well the HELOC we under budgeted so we
ran out of the HELOC and we still need
probably another five or six thousand
that get how much did you spend on your
Field of Dreams if you build it you will
come
about uh about 40 000 of the HELOC went
towards the ball field about 30 000 went
towards a well and pump that we needed
to put in anyway for our residents
what do you make a year we are I'm sorry
what do you make a year
two hundred thousand between my wife and
I okay
and your question is how to come up with
the last five thousand to finish
well yeah we're really hot and heavy in
step two we've already
tackled about 25
000 in debt within the last 30 to 40
days and so how long before starting how
long before baby step two is done
that's your current about another eight
months
is there a problem waiting until next
spring to finish the ball field
I mean well tactically technically is
there a problem I'm not talking about
emotionally
yeah yeah that's the big that's the hard
part right
um I think we earned about two thousand
dollars per month renting it out
um but it would take another six
thousand or so to finish it
yeah and each month we have about four
thousand dollars left over from
from income
who are you renting a baseball diamond
to
it they are in high demand out here
um it's hard to find fields to practice
on huh
so who's going to pay you like little
kids
whether it's no whether it's a youth a
lot of Youth teams or youth teams pay
two thousand dollars to rent a field no
if I've rented out 220 nights a week
100 bucks for a few hours
[Music]
okay uh if you want to work the cash
flow in to finish it that's fine I have
it's the the first time I've ever taken
a call on a baseball field
I'm
flabbergasted yeah if you build it he
will come man that's what came to mind
I hope this is not I hope your
projections are accurate and you haven't
spent this money and you've got to get
it all paid off now this goes into that
snowball by the way
maybe not this is the Ramsay show
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Angela starts off this hour in
Minneapolis hi Angela welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
yes I'm actually calling on behalf of my
mother-in-law
um unfortunately we lost our
father-in-law about a year ago and now
she's in kind of a tough financial
situation
because for their retirement they had
invested in someone else's life
insurance
and unfortunately put most of their
money in it and it hasn't paid out yet
yeah I don't and she has so little
information that she probably doesn't
even know what it's called
um
and I'm we're just yeah I just feel at a
loss for words how old is your
mother-in-law
she is 66 or 67. okay so retired just
retired she was a nurse
um she was not involved she's not
business savvy was not involved in the
decisions of the money in the household
much
not really I have a file on this issue
any kind of contacts on this issue
yes the problem is I
I haven't heard a call and make sure
it's even a legit
investment and she kind of
refuses to do that and just hopes it's
going to turn out okay
how can we help you
yeah so the problem is
they invested money and now thrown to
guessing they put in 200 to 300 000 if
they get it back it's about 550
000 that's if they get it back the
problem is the first 10 years they
didn't have to pay in
um and now that it's been over 10 years
they have to start paying in last year
she paid an 80 000 and this year by tax
census to paying 100 000 to keep
this investment going oh my and they
have to wait till this person passes
away in order to get the money back does
that make sense
yeah it's very unusual to have them
staged like this okay so let's start
with this okay the concept of a viadical
works like this
um the beneficiary let's say that I had
a life insurance policy my wife is the
beneficiary Sharon and um let's call it
a million dollar policy when I die and
my wife the beneficiary is supposed to
get a million dollars if they want money
beforehand the person that holds the
policy they can sell the position of the
beneficiary it's called a viadical and
it's discounted deeply and so if they
put 200 000 into one policy on one
person this is probably a multi-million
dollar policy
okay yeah and um uh you said it's only
supposed to pay out five hundred
thousand
she thinks she thinks she thinks again
yeah
and now that her father-in-law has
passed away he's the one who
unfortunately this was their retirement
money the only other money she has and
unfortunately unfortunately is she has
money in stocks yeah and now um and it's
only about 200 000 and then she and
that's the only other retirement money
she has besides Social Security okay
well first and let's just cover a couple
things uh your your angst inside of you
on this weird thing uh is good because
it's accurate this should not have been
done it's a horrible place for people to
put the majority of their money like
this absolutely horrible for multiple
reasons obviously we're waiting on
someone to die which is just weird okay
but that's what life insurance companies
do every day they wait on people to die
and hope they don't for a while and they
make more money on them that's how you
know so it's all weird but uh awkward
but but in addition to that it's an ex
it's a young
industry that is full of uh scam full of
fraud
and if it's not a scam or fraud a lot of
them are poorly structured and the
statistical analysis the Actuarial
analysis sucks
there are some legitimate companies that
aren't scams that are doing it but it's
nothing I would ever put a dime in
because it's just not got enough track
record that even if you could get past
the awkwardness of the weirdness of what
you're doing
um then even then it's not anything I
would put money into so uh
so what to do now is we've got first
we've got to figure out if it's a scam
second thing we've got to figure out is
there any exit prior to any exit
strategy prior to death and then the
third thing is all of this has to happen
because your mother-in-law actually
cares you she don't care right now she's
ashamed or she's afraid that it's bad
and she's like if she puts her hands
over her ears and closes her eyes and
goes la la la it's all going to go away
and be okay and that's not how this
works
so who's going to talk to her and get
permission to talk to this company in
writing
you are your husband
or one of our siblings yeah yeah and
it's almost like we have to force it
like yeah well the only reason we're
forcing it is for her own good because
I'm afraid she's gotten scammed
I mean the only other option is you walk
away from it all I mean I think no I'm
not walking away from it because she
refuses to face it
no I mean she might have to walk away
from it and just say it's a total loss
well if it's a scam she will
yeah and if she has to put money in that
she doesn't have she will
oh yeah yeah if she signed up for a
contract she can't fulfill she may lose
the whole stinking thing I don't know
you don't know I don't know what she
signed up for
you know so the first step is getting
her shook out of her fog and handing a
piece of paper that gives permission for
your husband her son if I'm
understanding this right
um to uh to to call these people or
someone in the family that has some
business Acumen to find out what the
flip is going on what these people have
gotten themselves into
it's a bad product because at best if
it's not a scam it's a young industry
that's poorly run the best of the best
of them are okay but nothing that makes
me want to jump up and down and get
involved in this weirdness
question really quick if you have time
if she just if we find out this is a bad
investment can she live off of 200 000
in Social Security for the rest of her
life
that depends on what she's willing to
spend
what's it take what's your monthly
budget
I mean she has her house paid off for
cars
and insurance and food and electricity
how much is the Social Security
she's making less than she thought after
her husband passed so about 2300 in a
month yeah 20 000 If It produced ten
percent would be 20 000 a year
our 200 000 would produce 20 000 a year
so a couple another couple Grand a month
give or take
um so she can live on three or four
grand she can make it probably if you
invest the money wisely this time this
remaining
um but yeah you guys need to get to the
bottom of this
[Music]
um
she she's ashamed that she doesn't
understand she's ashamed that she feels
like in the air she may have gotten
scammed and she may have so so in
general what would the Ramsey Show say
about Bionicles there is a portion of
them that are on the up and up and
there's no portion of them I would ever
do this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
was the last time you were excited about
Monday
What If instead of waking up exhausted
you felt exhilarated
you can't wait to get to work because
another day to do what you love doing
in a world where the bare minimum Monday
oh that makes me want to throw up has
taken the place of quiet quitting it's
clear that people are craving meaningful
work
yeah that's part of it
uh this is why career expert in Ramsey
personality Ken Coleman created the get
clear assessment to help you discover
your top talents passions and a clear
mission statement that'll help you find
the work the world needs you to do and
this week only the assessment is ten
dollars off the sale ends at midnight on
Friday so get this deal right now go to
ramseysolutions.com get clear
Chris is with us in Seattle hey Chris
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks for taking my calls sure what's
up
I have about a hundred thousand dollars
in cash
um oh about ninety seven thousand
dollars in two real estate properties
um and the question is should I take
that cash and pay them off the
hesitation and the backstory
um these are realistic properties that I
kind of got entangled I got myself
entangled into this so I'm taking
responsibility for this I got into these
deals to flip these back in 2007 with uh
um someone who I knew real well trusted
and they had done one of this personally
came up to me and said hey you know what
we should do this you know it'll be it
will be a great it'll be a great deal
you can make some quick easy money I was
naive 15 years ago
um so did that then we had the crash of
2008 and then became on on a reluctant
landlord
um and over the years just kind of
struggled with managing those and
eventually got myself further entangled
by signing these over to uh sort of
management company they put it into a
trust and they essentially manage the
tenants collect the rent they pay the
mortgage they do make the mortgage
payments they handle all repairs and
everything however I am still the
mortgage holder with my original
mortgage company so I have liability but
I'm not going to really get the benefit
if that real estate property was sold
today and made a profit this some
company will essentially take all of
that but what
um and in exchange for that they
essentially handle everything so the to
my original question what the thing that
keeps me up at night right now and they
I've had no problems with them um for
the record they have made all the
payments they have handled everything
um but the thing that keeps me up at
night right now where the anxiety is
coming from is I have this liability
um it is if wherever if I went to go
take a loan out today I will be asked
questions questions about that and I
have to go through the explanation of
what they are what's currently going on
here is the proof that pins are being
paid and everything is kept up to date
because I I collect those on a regular
basis
so the thought crossed my mind that I
should
um
does the trust pay the payment on the
property that you're talking about
paying off
yes that's correct what happens if you
pay it off and there's not a payment
anymore do you receive that
well so that was that was my question
the question was does it make sense
well it's in cash essentially become the
only mortgage holder refinance these
properties so that I no longer have
these on my credit report and it's not
something that I'm carrying so my
question is my question is
under the terms of the crap you signed
up for
yep well they pay you the payment that
they used to pay to the bank if you pay
the bank off
I don't have a good answer to that and
obviously if you get zero from them as a
result of paying it off you don't pay it
off
yes but that's the culmination of the
second bad deal you did on these
properties
yes
um
so you gave up ownership of the
properties and they wrapped it into a
trust so there was not a due on sale
Clause because they didn't want to pay
off the mortgages
that is correct but you don't have if
you pay off the mortgages it doesn't
increase does that increase your Equity
position no because they're taking all
the equity right
that is correct um I guess you're giving
them an extra hundred thousand dollars
by paying the loan off aren't you
if uh so I guess this is my question
because I am I am some I am still
somewhat naive and I'm beginning to do
some research here when the thought came
but I figured I got through FPU which is
kind of how I started getting all of
this stuff cleaned up and I figured I'd
make the phone call in the event that I
essentially refinanced this loan where
whether it's an LLC or whatever it's not
it's not a refinance honey it's just
you're gonna pay it off
okay okay and then the question is
twofold under this trust agreement that
you have signed over the property rights
if you pay off the mortgage do they
protect that and you get that back at
resale when they sell it because you've
given up the equity you said
but will they take the uh will they give
you the hundred thousand dollars at sale
and will they pay you payments until
then
got it okay because otherwise you're
you're now you know
uh they're they're getting ahead by the
payments and by the hundred thousand
dollars that they now added to their
um
you know their Equity if we don't do
this so I don't know what you've signed
up for it's a weird
deal that you've gotten yourself into I
think I know why they did it I think
they did it to avoid the do on sale
Clause of the of the deed of trust but
uh that's correct yeah it's one of these
um nothing down real estate crap weekend
seminars that God that these guys went
to they have no money but they thought
they'd come in and run the property for
you and they make all the money and made
you think that you were somehow
protected and you're not
so um
because if they just walk away
you're right back where you were
that is correct yeah except you don't
have the property in your name anymore
yeah the property is in the trust yeah
so you've lost control of the property
all you've got is the uh all you've got
is the liability
so I don't know I mean I I do not want
to give them a hundred thousand dollars
more
so we need to make sure that you know
that you get something documented with
them that they will pay that out to you
uh upon the sale of the property if you
reduce it if they will pay that out to
you and they will pay you payments in
the meantime then yes I would pay it off
and get rid of the liability
that sounds terrible this is like
terrible terrible bad idea hour I mean
no wonder he said I mean he sounded like
he was just wired man no wonder that's
crazy stuff
okay
um
let's kind of pause a second and talk
about a concept
the concept is this from him and uh from
a caller in a different segment
um depending on how you're watching this
or listening you'll be catching it at a
different time but
um about viaticals buying out life
insurance policies
um
I have done Dumber things than both of
those two things
every time I did it was
due to most of the time due to being
desperate or being greedy
if you're desperate is right after you
get desperate you're gonna get broke and
that's his thing okay he gotten a bad
deal with a partner 2007 horrible timing
on real estate law you know the guy then
he had to get that guy gone but he ends
up with the property and the property's
killing him and he's not making any
money on it so these other guys will
come in they'll they'll will pay the
payments but we get all the equity and
and we'll send you the rents
or we'll keep the wrench or whatever the
arrangement was and you have to deed
your property into the name of a trust
that those other guys control so you've
now lost the ownership of the property
but the mortgage is still in your name
you still have the liability that's what
he did and that was a man that was
desperate yeah it would have to be yeah
because that's like known as a deal that
sucks
and so
um
and I've seen that deal pitched as a way
to get a property for nothing down just
take over their payments and manage it
for them but you got to get it into your
name and you make the equity later and
that's one of those nothing down weekend
real estate things or those Tic Tac
things that they're doing that's going
around
I mean this nothing down real estate
comes around about every 10 or 15 years
again and then right after that a whole
bunch of people lose their butt and then
a whole whole fresh batch of young
people have to come along to be dumb
enough to do it again well they're here
yeah it's a fresh batch
fresh batch of mbas that are 34 years
old
the fresh batch
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Jerry
and Christy are with us hey guys how are
you hi Dave welcome welcome where do you
guys live Fort Worth ah welcome to
Tennessee good to have you and how much
debt have you two paid off
863 288
36 months whoa and your range of income
during that time uh started out at 165
plus bonus of 80 000 up to 185 with a
bonus of 180 000.
wow big shovel okay what do you guys do
for a living uh Construction in the
oilfield business
and I manage our properties okay all
right and so uh what kind of debt was
your 863
000. David was like a CVS receipt
we had 18 line items and uh credit cards
85k loans 54k some of those loans were
because I never paid interest on credit
cards so once the zero percent thing ran
out I would get a refinance thing and
then Auto and ATV 25 second house 357
and land 342. wow okay how long you two
been married since 2019 okay and uh so
no no no no
2009 2009 and we we had nothing in 2007.
it just went by so fast it's just been
so good it went by fast and we had zero
at 2007 when we met okay so in 2019 was
about three years ago 20 was three years
ago so uh that's about the time you
started all of this what happened they
put you guys in gear you all went after
it well it started a few years prior to
that we were both oil filled in the six
figures doing really good except the
company I worked for was going through
financial problems uh ultimately went
bankrupt and so there were routine
layoffs and if you drove a company truck
and I did then when you got to work
however many taxis were lined up that's
how many company truck people were going
that day and it was very stressful but I
I survived it little did we know and we
were like 400 in debt then little did we
know that I'm through the stress wagon
of my company getting laid off he gets
laid off
wow and that was we still gained a lot
more debt after that but then October of
2019 I listened to Total Money Makeover
and I listened to the book in one trip
coming and going and I came home and
told him about it
so Jerry what'd she say when she came
home said we're going to try this
wasn't a question it was it was a
statement it was a statement you're
going to do this we're going to do this
and I said okay we'll try it whatever we
got to do something different we got to
do something different yeah so the 863
was uh half of that was mortgages yes
including your personal home well that's
a funny story so when we bought the
property we bought 117 Acres at the time
but we actually sold another house to
buy this property so we decided well
we're going to count uh survey off four
acres and the house and we paid cash for
that so nobody could ever take that away
from us all we had to do is worry about
taxes in and if something ever happened
to our jobs we could always just sell
everything else and we still had our
house yeah so that piece of land
surrounding it you also paid off yes so
kind of like paying off your house yes
but you had already carved it out and
replanted it yes way to go I like that
wow yeah it was it's you know added to
where we're like 150 acres there we love
land we love real estate okay y'all did
not did you you must have sold something
because your income is showing 300 and
you paid off over 300 a month a year
when we sold this
house so we had a lot of you sold the
357 yeah yes oh okay that makes a number
and we sold it we sold a cattle herd we
sold implements and then every bonus
went to the every dollar budget and then
so what did the herd and the implements
bring uh probably the herd was like
around 35 000 the implements maybe 20
30. so about 50 more so 400 and some
change came from sellings to big stuff
yeah of the 863 right and then your cash
flow the rest of it in 36 months yeah
how'd that feel how'd that feel
emotionally having to sell off all that
for him the implements he'd rather lose
an arm or a leg than to sell anything
any heavy equipment or any Implement uh
the the cattle herd was really hard for
me yeah yeah that was tough but but uh
we we had a goal we knew and then I
loved the second house that was tough
not will you rebuild the herd now with
cash we have we already have we started
doing the same thing with the implements
only better yes yeah better better toys
this time yeah that's it
wow so it's working that's what I did
yeah I've not heard but the toys and
that's what we looked at it when we
started this we said hey it's a
short-term deal we're going to get it
done we're going to do it and then after
that then we can do whatever we want to
do we can buy whatever we want to do all
we got to do is okay later we can live
and give like no one else I just like
just like get stuff done yeah well what
was tough with that second house is that
house was but not only 100 mortgage I
remember her telling me Oh we can 100
mortgage plus all your closing costs
because it was a private Credit Union
that I had dealt with for 30 years and
had a very good record so they uh that
it's scary having a in an oilfield Town
yeah to have a house and five acres with
100 mortgage plus you know you don't
know when it gets cyclical and what did
it bring like four 425 okay so you got
out of it clean yeah yeah and then we
still had some well yeah a little bit of
equity yeah yeah so that all went to it
yeah wow I had to go you guys how's it
feel to be free great yeah it's
fantastic it's still unreal like when
you ever go back no no no no it's just
no way and we change the way you feel it
when the work's volatile does it change
the way you feel at work oh yeah you
know right now somebody says something
work and say I don't have to be here
guys
I had my retirement already set up I
have a house my place is already I don't
have any debts I can walk home tomorrow
yeah it's not going to hurt me a bit but
we'll work this out we'll work this only
reason I'm working now is she wants a
new house and a new barn as soon as I
have the cash to build both of those I'm
gone oh just like that okay that's it
all right there we go we'll do other
stuff one more year
I love it
go ahead and turn in your notice
but I was a zero percent interest queen
and I always thought with zero percent
interest that's free and the one book
the audiobook just changed it Total
Money Maker that was it yes yeah you
know I had heard about you on AM radio
stations but but yeah I didn't we didn't
believe it we really didn't believe it
and even today it's hard to really
believe this is a huge number that we
did you know 863
000 in 36 months but what's dumb is that
that bank would loan us 100 so my quote
is with debt just because you can
doesn't mean you should yeah right on
and they'll loan you more than they
should and you should yeah we were
paying 3 800 a month in interest it was
just crazy but you know a lot of people
will say well I could do that with that
big of a shovel right but the bigger the
shovel the bigger the mountain and well
you turn loose to some things that meant
something to you yeah and you turn loose
to some stuff you were going glad to get
rid of that one both uh but you turned
loose of a bunch of stuff as part of the
equation and there's something when
visually
a house leaves cattle leave implements
leaves you see that there's something
happens transforming in your heart when
that stuff right in front of your face
starts leaving in order to accomplish
the goal that's a permanent change you
will not go back in debt no yeah it was
not easy for you because of the emotions
of it exactly right yeah and I just want
to tell you thank you so much because I
had spent my whole life
having good income and shuffling money
yeah and not really knowing until I was
doing my income taxes how much I'd spent
over the year wow and we're proud of you
you guys are impressive well we got a
copy uh we got the live and give bundle
for you the baby steps millionaires book
you're there already I'm sure with the
value of that land yeah and uh The Total
Money Makeover book as well and the
Financial Peace University membership
use them or give them they're for you
guys to say thank you for coming in
telling your story you're impressive
people thank you thank you so much so
proud of you Heroes well done very very
well done Jerry and Christy Fort Worth
Texas
863 paid off in 36 months making about
three hundred dollars around it with all
these bonuses and stuff coming in and
they sold a bunch of stuff count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three one
two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America and thank you for all of you
that have joined us recently our numbers
are way up we appreciate that if you
guys want to help us if we've been a
blessing to you
there's a couple of ways you can do that
one is you can subscribe where you
listen or view the show for instance if
you're YouTube or a podcast just hit the
Subscribe button you can share the show
a lot of a lot of these uh Services
Spotify or whatever you can share the
link you can share whatever there's a
share button where you can send it to
your friends let them know to listen and
we'd love to have that if you're just
listening on talk radio then just share
it just tell your friends hey here's
where I listen to the show you need to
do that and you can leave us where
you're able to you can leave us a
five-star review one Stars don't help
Mama said if you ain't anything nice to
say don't say anything at all so just uh
you know fill out those five star
reviews those three things really help
the algorithms uh last week we were the
number uh 16 podcast in the world whoop
whoop
out of an apple out of uh out of about
two to three million podcasts that are
out there and that's because of you guys
thank you for that and uh our team says
we should be in the top ten uh I think
we're doing pretty good at 16 but we'll
take we'll take moving on up if you guys
share it and move us along and we get
more and more and more listeners uh
we're up there fighting with the big
dogs on the porch anyway so thank you
thank you for that we appreciate you AJ
is with us AJ is in Kansas City hi AJ
welcome to the Ramsey Show
okay thanks for taking my call sure um
just give a little back sorry real quick
my wife is involved in an accident and
her van somebody ran a red light and
total our van so that leads me to my
question is should I use some of our
emergency fund to add cash to purchase a
better used car
how's your wife doing
she is healing she's fine overall but
she's she's got some healing to do
thankfully it it wasn't it could have
been a lot worse so it wasn't thankfully
wow do you guys have any debt
well you know we uh got that free um
right before our Twins were born uh two
years ago okay they're right after two
months after the Twins were born we paid
off our what what was your extra car
worth how much money are you going to
get the uh we already we just got the
check I settled on that we got 9 000 or
8 500 that's that's including the sales
tax okay she got medical coverage as
well you're gonna get for her the
medical stuff will all be just fine she
wasn't at fault so we're we're dealing
with all that stuff right
yes yeah that's all that's all separate
from it I'm just trying to get us a van
right now right now I'm using my
mother-in-law's van yeah okay what do
you have set aside
just just the emergency fund so
I guess I'm saying three three or six
months do you have set aside
we we have 36k in our emergency funds
what's your household income
household income is 135. okay
all right well in general uh an upgrade
in vehicle is not considered an
emergency
yes yeah but um if you want to use some
of your emergency fund because you're
saying uh I think we're stable and 30 is
plenty we might have had it over funded
um then that's fine but if you feel like
you're vulnerable
to an emergency because of that then you
should not do that
okay because this is not an upgrade
upgrade's not an emergency but you make
a lot of money to be driving a 9 000 van
it was paid off man it was good I know I
know but I'm just saying you were
probably you probably one of your next
goals was to cash flow and upgrade
wasn't it yes we have we have nineteen
thousand dollars in cash and then I
still have a car to trade in as well
that I think will give me like eight or
nine so I was looking at like I'm
confused where's the thirty six thousand
so the 30 36 000 is our emergency fund
we were cash flowing a new car because I
wanted to get my wife in a better van
now that we were doing better so uh the
19 is separate than the 36. oh why do
you need to use your emergency fund
you have nine plus 19 is 28.
yeah what did you want to spend Mark is
just crazy no it's not so what I'm
looking at I can like I'm looking at
like a 26 000 van that has like 85 000
miles well you've got 28 you got twenty
eight thousand dollars
is the 19 include the nine
uh uh that you just got from the
insurance company
yes it does
yes
we just got nine for her Vans uh so you
have 19 in cash and the other car is
that you're willing to trade in is a it
was a third car
correct yeah and it's worth what
yeah I think eight or nine is that not
enough for you it is it is that's why
I'm just if I if I spend a little bit
more if that's uh well like two thousand
more dude you got enough car you're
moving from 9 to 28.
that's enough that's what I thought you
were going to say so I want to make sure
yeah I'm doing that on principle not on
math okay yeah I know I need to eat some
Humble Pie yeah this is you you're
you're not moving from nine to fourteen
you're moving from 9 to 28. you're 3xing
your car
okay that's fine and then if you want to
move up later and pay cash as long as
your total of your vehicles doesn't
equal more than half your annual income
I'll be fine with that but no you don't
need to hit your emergency fund you
don't have a need to
and that's a good discipline factor for
you that's true to say in the middle of
an emotional thing my wife
was injured this is a horrible wreck uh
the van is the kid hauler it's where we
call the twins yes uh there's a lot of
emotion around this and it's a good
practice to say okay the emotion that
I'm feeling around getting a better car
is not an emergency yeah that's that's a
very good point Dave I mean if he's like
a thousand fifteen hundred off from
where he wants to be I mean can he not
just cash flow that little bit or
whatever he's been doing can he do it
another month and have the money for it
I wouldn't pull from the emergency fund
for that no it's not another I mean
rather the mother-in-law's van for
another month I wouldn't do it I'd just
buy that gum car I would too but twenty
thousand twenty five thousand dollars in
pay cash that's what I would do yeah
okay took a little bit to get down into
the numbers there they were uh some of
those were hiding behind the barn he's
got his eye on a specific vehicle yeah
go take a cold shower and help the car
favor car fever will get you every time
Lori's with us in Los Angeles hi Lori
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you for taking my call it is a
thrill to talk with you Dave and Jade
and
um I today I am happy to be making this
call uh Having learned what I have and
I'm in the position I am because I've
been following the uh Ramsay thank you
hey we're short on time go straight to
your question kiddo
okay I've got a situation I've never
ever heard I'm very lopsided I'm nearly
62. I've got over about 1.1 million in
equity in a home I own that's been
rental property
I don't I have very little in retirement
account and
um I am trying to decide going forward
what will be the best step for me in
terms of
uh moving back into the house uh I it's
kind of a I've got a little bit of a you
know more complicated situation but I'm
really lopsided that's what I've never
heard addressed in any of your shows and
so you have you have a lot of equity and
no money
yes yeah that would be it yeah then you
may need to move you may need to move
this property because what you need to
end up with Lori is a paid for property
and a nest egg to live on by the time
you get to 70. and just moving back into
this house doesn't do that I don't think
and that there with maybe more to your
story because there's we're short on
time as I said but
um it sounds like that um that this
property's left over from some other
stuff in your life yeah because she's
living somewhere now I wonder why she
can't stay where she's at and sell off
this property yeah once you can she's
renting though Probably sounds like so
yeah running out of time here and uh
yeah we're out of time here
okay
or not oh my gosh okay so um yeah that's
what I would do here that's what I would
get the property sold and uh
and I would get into something where I
can pay for something out with all that
equity and I'm having this thing left
over maybe a condo she could buy yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Frank is in Detroit hey Frank welcome to
the Ramsey Show hey Dave um great to be
on here thanks for taking my call I
found you probably only about six months
ago I don't know how and I'm so glad I
did well we're honest
listen to every day when I'm running and
walking and working out and then I
preach at the dinner table to the kids
all day but my question is
uh we started getting this you know we
get this bill every year and my wife
opened it and said um here it is it's
that insurance thing I go oh that's that
thing Dave talks about it's the whole
the whole the whole life insurance I
said we don't want that so I looked into
it gave them a call they told me it's
currently worth 28 000 in cash and my
death benefit is 75. if I learn from you
enough I could take that 28 put it in
some good growth mutual funds every
seven years of a double 10 years I
already have the benefit of the 75 000.
am I thinking right
well you also need to make sure you're
replacing it with term life and you need
to make sure you've got the term life
policy in place before you cash out the
whole life you have a life insurance in
place already
well that was the other thing I thought
from um watching and learning I actually
retired and I'm at the point now where I
think I'm self-insured I don't if I pass
away
um my pension actually goes up for my
wife because I took a reduced benefit
when um I can put her on there and then
our LLC brings in um a yearly income
also about uh 60 000 a year that would
remain the same so I'm thinking at this
point if something happens to me you
know she's she's fine is the pension no
you know that is the pension the only
retirement account you have or is there
do you have some IRAs or anything like
that anywhere laying around yeah yeah I
have I have my pension which luckily I
was a government employee and I I mean I
don't apologize for it but they promised
us years ago but I put 33 years in at
work and I get Lifetime Health Care
included in that for me and my wife good
so the bottom line is she's she's okay
with no life insurance correct okay
correct then yes just cancel cancel this
and invest it you're exactly right I
love that for you okay way to go man
what was that very well done and we
appreciate having you as a new listener
and uh the good news is you're actually
learn to do something you got 28 000
bucks here because here's the thing if
he dies they don't pay 75 plus 28 right
they keep the 28.
isn't that interesting that's what I
would call thievery that's what I would
call a bad investment that when you die
they keep your money yeah yeah that's a
bad investment cash value life insurance
sucks now the question I asked I wanted
to ask him about his pension because my
initial thought was if all he has is the
pension it might be worth it to keep a
term life policy because we don't know
like a pension can die with you or a
pension if the if the company goes under
there's some risk there it's always a
good idea to have a nest egg but um yeah
I would do that and then watch this 28
grow and then at some point in the
future you might pick up a couple
hundred thousand it sounds like he's a
runner he's probably in good shape yeah
and uh so you know you probably pick it
up for very little and just a couple
hundred thousand cost of a pizza
probably check sander Insurance to see
what that costs Frank and uh it might be
worth it for the peace of mind I kept a
couple million extra around
um that I didn't need it was just swi
Sharon wants it that's all it was it had
nothing to do with financial planning it
was uh it was a marriage planning I feel
the same way once it s w i there we go I
feel the same way well if you make
enough money I can I can put some stuff
in the column yeah that doesn't make
sense except that swi yeah right so
that's okay you just got to do that and
we finally dropped that policy uh I
guess it was last year but that thing's
been around forever but the price for
you to have that policy you could light
that amount of money on fire and you
would it wasn't that expensive and she
said you know her comment was I'd rather
you buy me that than some more shiny
sparkly Rock things well you know you
got to say it with her accent and uh
David yeah my name becomes a seven
syllable word when it's I'm in trouble
there you go all right Pete is with us
Pete's in San Antonio hi Pete welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi there good afternoon uh thank you so
much for taking my call I really
appreciate it sure how can we help
so I'm calling because um so I actually
had a change in um in my financials here
I was recently laid off from my employer
um at the beginning of this year in
January and because of my Tinder there
I'm going to continue to receive a
severance pay that's gonna uh continue
to pay me at the same rate how's your
new job
so I haven't found a new employer yet
why it's March it's been three months
almost four no
so um my white box actually works also
and I we have been discussing and I
decided to return back to school
full-time so I am currently enrolled in
school for what
uh to finish my degree uh my my degree
and what
it's computer information systems
um and why do you need that
well so and that's kind of a part of my
question is so uh my history background
of employment has really been in finance
um and I'm trying to kind of pair that
with the new uh the new kind of computer
side of that to you know hopefully give
me even better paint job than what I've
had
um and you need a four-year degree in
information systems to do that there's
not a some courses that you'd like a
certificate or a
something less expensive
well so there there are a couple things
as far as you know they're in certain
languages and programming and whatnot uh
I just from the the kind of the
opportunities I was looking for and
other employers to apply for they
typically do ask for that four-year
degree
um and some of the opportunities around
here so I kind of where did you hear
that
three years ago because you know that's
changed dramatically in the last 36
months
the job sites for certain employers
around my area that I was interested in
applying for I just found that they
typically asked for that four-year
degree so okay what did you used to make
so I
finally
um
my social employee full-time and what
does sure yeah you said that what does
she make
uh she made a little over 92 000 last
year so combined for gross we were about
188 000. uh net we're 140. how old are
you
937 okay and your question is what sir
kind of time to what we spoke about so
in this time this time I'm barely
legal school full-time and was just
wondering for first uh with the income
we have right now saved and our savings
and my continuing Severance if we should
apply that towards uh paying off an auto
loan and a credit card yes um or you're
making you make a hundred thousand
dollars a year in your household right
now well you're paying cash for this
education right
yes ma'am okay
and how long does the severance continue
until the end of September yeah you
don't even need your Severance to live
though you can surely to God you can
live on 100 Grand in Sacramento I mean
in San Antonio
uh yes sir I just have my my mortgage
auto loan and uh you won't have the auto
loan anymore we just paid it off
okay yes sir and that's kind of my
second part I just wanted to double
check is if you feel like I would be
able to continue to go to school full
time and I wouldn't I wouldn't do what
you're doing I would go get a job making
100 and let them pay for your education
and finish your education in the
evenings
and get your four-year degree I mean
you're already making 100 Grand dude
um and I don't mind your career
aspirations but I think this idea that I
got fired so I'm going to quit and go to
school you're hiding I think you need to
get back to work this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America it's a free
call here at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you're wondering
whether to buy or sell a home this year
here's what you need to know about the
housing market
there's still more buyers than sellers
more demand than there are homes
the median price is expected to keep
Rising
just at a slower rate we're anticipating
a seven percent increase in house prices
this year
interest rates haven't stopped going up
except for when they went down
for a week there I don't know if you
jumped in and took advantage of the
downturn in the market or not but that
was an opportunity for you to lock in
your mortgage if you haven't you might
want to check what Churchill Mortgage
and see if you can still get in on one
of those lower rates that slipped up
after the little Bank collapse over
there in California
so um if you hadn't heard there was a
little Bank thing over happened over
there California and uh California and
uh that's uh that's why you need to work
with an experienced real estate agent
when you get ready to start buying or
selling a home in a market that is
returned to normal
it now takes about 90 to 120 days to
sell a house and very few people get 100
of asking price
that is a normal real estate market it
has been that way most of my life and
I'm old
so that's how that works it was one
little blip back in 2020 there when we
lost our minds and I mean I'll tell you
how crazy that was used cars went up in
value the Mississippi ran backward for
two days I mean it's like unbelievable
Okay so now it's back to normal and you
can find agents that'll walk you through
this process that are Ramsay trusted
these are our endorsed local providers
they're high octane high protein real
estate agents they get her done just
like that get her done that's simple so
check it out ramseysolutions.com agent
and get a Ramsey trusted agent and get
moving time to do a real estate deal
Emily's with us in San Diego hi Emily
welcome to the Ramsay show
so hi Dave thanks for taking my phone
call sure what's up
so
um I am going to in the next couple
months inherit a little bit of money
from my father and it's not a huge
amount probably between maybe 50 to 70
000 and um financially me and my husband
are doing good
um we do have younger kids so I'm
wondering what would be the best
decision for us to invest that money to
possibly let it grow and have more
wealth for our children
do you already have money set aside for
their education
we did not
um my husband is a disabled veteran so
they will get some of their college paid
for
when you say some some most of it most
of it you know if it were me I'd
probably put it in like a brokerage
account where you can earmark it for
them but just for Mutual mutual funds
and you just say it's our money and if
we want to give it to the kids later we
can I would not move it to their names I
don't it doesn't serve any purpose
um
you all got any debt left
we we have done pretty well with our
debt I have one credit card and then we
have
um just like we remodeled our kitchen
that has not too high of a balance
um not too bad with interest and those
are really the only like how much that
we have uh the kitchen I have about 8
000 and then I have about 8 000 on my
cards and I'm changing my answer here
let's let's go back and retake this test
um I think you need to pay off your debt
and I need I think you need to stop
going into debt
and then whatever you have left after
this you have three to six months saved
as an emergency fund
we do we have about 40 000 in savings
that's good okay so let's go back and
clean up this debt and swear that we're
not going into debt anymore and then
whatever you have left you can throw
into that brokerage account
fair enough just just it's uh
how much do you owe in your home
our home we purchased about three years
ago
it but we have like a 2.75 interest rate
right now
okay and your household income is what
um net it's about 1 30. okay
Emily I um I get the impression that
you've uh listened to us for a fairly
short period of time is that fair
yes I it's just been about the last
couple months when I kind of figured
that I would be getting an inheritance
and I've never invested before so okay
and here's what here's what we teach
we have learned and we teach it because
for 30 years we've taught it and we've
LED more people to become what we call
Baby Steps millionaires than anybody
else out there and we've LED 10 million
people out of debt and into wealth is
what it amounts to over many many years
of doing this so what we're looking for
and really what you're looking for at
your core is what is the fastest right
way to build wealth
okay by right way I mean not taking
weird risks we're not talking about
playing the roulette wheel in Vegas or
cryptocurrency or some kind of weird
crap right but just what's the fastest
way to build wealth okay that is that is
not that that's safe that's good the
first thing we've discovered as we've
studied 10 000 millionaires in the
largest study a Millionaire's ever done
is they get out of debt and they stay
out of debt like it's a disease
okay and um I I've got to move you onto
that planet because you're still using
words about your debt like oh it's no
big deal it's only eight thousand
dollars like a little bit left over from
this and it's all we've got a mortgage
but it's only two percent like you want
to keep it like it's a pet okay and so I
gotta move you off of that planet in
order to get you to move towards the
wealth the fastest way I can get you
there you can do whatever you want to do
you're a grown-up okay but uh the
fastest way for your children to end up
wealthy is for you to first become
wealthy
and so then you don't have to worry
about whether this fifty thousand turned
into wealth or not if you follow that so
we're going to get you completely debt
free because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and right
now in your mindset it all comes in and
it's okay for a bunch of it to go over
to the bank instead of into an
investment
and we've got to stop that regardless of
the interest rate it's a cash flow
problem and so we're going to clean up
those two debts we're going to make sure
you keep that 40 000 in place and that's
our first three baby steps the the
fourth baby step is be putting 15 of
your income out of your monthly budget
into retirement 401ks Roth IRAs with
matching not with matching whatever in
good growth stock mutual funds baby step
five is kids college is addressed six is
pay off the house early now you've saved
nothing for kids college because you
have a wonderful benefit from your
husband's uh service tell him thank you
for his service from us please
so basically with the Forty thousand and
you take the 50 and you pay off the 16
that leaves us 34. I'm probably going to
sit down with a broker if you don't have
one click smartvest or pro at
ramseysolutions.com and I'm probably
going to open up a couple of 529s and
dump about 10 grand into each little
kid's name into the two 529s it's not a
lot if you never do anything else that's
probably okay because you got most of
their stuff covered the veterans
benefits on this or the disabled vet's
benefits are incredible for your kids
and they should be and I'm glad as a
taxpayer I get the opportunity to be a
blessing to your family for your service
and so it's one of the few things I'm
happy about with my taxes but the um so
so you got that but I want a little bit
more in there like Jake said and then
everything after that in your budget
that you have extra money left over and
you'll have more money because you're
only payments now except your house
payment I want you to start
concentrating on getting rid of this
house debt
and so if we did throw 16 at the debt
that leaves 34 and we put 20 into the
kids I'm going to use 14 for some fun
things like a trip or something uh or
just upgrading a car or an item in the
house that's a good idea or I'm gonna
pay down on the mortgage baby step six
so Emily I'm going to send you a copy of
the book baby steps millionaires which
will walk you through how to become a
millionaire following this stuff without
a bunch of risks and with a bunch of
craziness because you really make you've
done a good job with your money I just
I'm fine-tuning it to turn it up to
great
because there's a lot of different
things going on in this conversation
thank you for the call
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage David and Kelly are with us hey
guys how are you hey how are you howdy
better than I deserve welcome where do
you live Richlands Virginia ah just up
the road well welcome to Nashville good
to have you guys how much debt have you
paid off we've paid off 335 thousand
dollars good for you and your how long
did this take 26 months good and your
range of income during that two years
275 up to 350. wow what do you guys do
for a living I'm a pharmacist and a
realtor and an electrician and a
carpenter okay renaissance man and I'm a
pharmacist and a pharmacist two two
Pharmacy degrees and uh that must have
been some of the 335. it was uh 180 was
student loans together
Freedom yeah and then cars truck my SUV
and credit cards all right so you're
normal how long you all been married 18
years okay so what happened uh in that
15th or 16th year that was the wake up
and uh got you on this Ramsay way so
somebody years and years ago had
mentioned Dave Ramsey to us but we
started listening to I started listening
to the YouTube channel and that's
literally I was doing construction jobs
and started listening to YouTube the
Ramsey Show and that was literally what
turned it on for us it took a little bit
to get me on here I drag her along yeah
he felt the need first and kept saying
well this this this and I was like oh no
no I want a new car and we got a new car
and then they kept saying we need to
sell the car and I'm going no we're not
selling the car and we kept listening to
the podcast you had a smart car yeah
but that was a little bitty car oh my
goodness a little bit it's a pregnant
roller skin yes it is and so I didn't
want to sell the car kept pushing us and
then I we would be listening to the
podcast and I'd be he'd be out in the
garage I'd run out there and I said Dave
said if we could pay off the car in 18
months we could keep the car I'm keeping
the car we're paying it off oh so that
was the motivation so this is the red
SUV is the one she's talking about it's
not a picture okay because I'm like all
of this over a smart car I don't
understand
no it's so nice
so for you for you then Kelly it was the
give and take if we if we go fast and we
get intense then that means we get to
keep the truck absolutely got it got it
got it yeah that works but yes so the
whole thing from the podcast it
literally I went from the YouTube from
the YouTube and now we've we've used the
Ramsey Show on the app and we also
bought some books but we've given them
all away and we'll buy some more books
and we give them all away so but also it
was at our church too we had already got
started into the journey and then they
did a financial peace class at church
and we went to that also oh okay so you
did get in and drink okay and I had
already drunk it at that point I gotta
helped get her on board okay cool cool
cool we literally worked 18 12 to 18
hours a day every day but Church nights
y'all been working Maniacs yes sir we
were faithful to our job faithful to our
church and then any other holidays
nights weekend holidays one time I
remember uh we had worked through the
night on a Saturday or through the day
on a Saturday and it was late late
Saturday night I didn't realize how late
it actually was Dave and and I was
carrying some tools out to the truck
like I said I do construction I was
carrying some tools out and I I heard
Parts chirping over in the trees and I
thought well that's really weird why are
birds chirping in the middle of the
night right that didn't make any sense
to me and then I noticed some light
coming from this direction didn't
realize that was the East and it was a
Saturday night right you had worked all
the way through I had worked all night
long wow I had worked all night long wow
I crashed out about three he'd come and
woke me up at five and said the birds
were chirping it's time to go so we went
home slept from about seven to nine went
on to church at ten and and that
finished up our day and needless to say
we were tired on Sunday night if you
were toast then yeah so do people think
you were crazy I mean you guys were just
you're going hard yeah did people what
were people saying what was your family
saying what were your friends saying
they said we were crazy but we really
didn't take their opinion there you go
they weren't the ones that felt the
weight of the death and we did we felt
the weight of the Dead We felt like we
needed to get out from under it what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is now that you did it we talked
about this before what would we say if
you asked us I think that staying
faithful to church and to the God and
let him take care of the rest
and faithful to go to work because uh
good place to go I know that's right
yeah I mean he's faithful to feed the uh
the sparrow but he doesn't throw the
worms into the nest no yeah so you went
out there drug it and killed in drug at
home I mean he gave you the work to do
he gave you the energy to do we talked
about that as well and gave the energy
to do it every single time he gave us
the jobs the right number of tools the
right place to do it close enough to
home I work at a little hospital about
20 minutes from the house and literally
every job that I got was on the way home
like it wasn't I didn't have to drive an
hour and a half or two hours to get to
work because I would have wasted all a
whole evening right if I had to drive an
hour to get somewhere but we'd stay
working till 11 12 o'clock at night and
then roll in get some about five six
hours of sleep and head back out to work
the next morning amazing where the
energy went after we're done paying off
the debt I'm like I just don't have that
energy well I bet it feels good to sleep
now
now you can have a normal schedule you
don't have to be working through the
night well you paid a price to win I'm
sure you'll never forget it no you'll
never forget it and you'll never go back
not going back and you changed your
family tree I mean that's powerful was
it worth it it was absolutely yeah it
was for sure way to go Heroes well done
I'm proud of you thank you very very
good stuff that's powerful stuff sure
and um you know it's
um
when you can work together
the way you guys have knit the way
you've been unified in this approach
didn't start that way but I mean the
more you got into it the more it became
unified the more you you start to
realize we can slay any dragon if we do
it together that's true and so the next
thing to come along will be a money
thing it'll be something else no because
you'll be ready you'll be ready because
you know if you don't do it together
that you can do anything and when we
would go to all those second jobs and
whatever we would bring Addison and you
know it's just still family time we're
just working on a job somewhere else
instead of at our house we were at
somebody else's house working oh
absolutely yeah I mean that's that's
there's and again it's not for life it
was for 26 months yes you know and out
of 18 years of marriage and now you're
free for the rest of your life with a
fabulous a couple of incomes a couple of
Pharmacy incomes you can do you're going
to make a lot of money and you're going
to be wealthy unbelievably and in a
position to be unbelievably generous
now you're going to be able to do
everything you want to do so well done
you guys very well done okay who are
your biggest cheerleaders
probably each other
it was a little girl sitting over there
I love it all right I love it well let's
bring Addison up how old is Addison
she's eight eight okay she's been
practicing her debt free screen oh yes
she got y'all got matching better than I
deserve t-shirts for those of you
listening only uh you ought to see this
line up here it's pretty pretty sweet
very well done hey we've got the uh live
and give boxer bundle for you that
includes the baby steps Millionaire's
book number one bestseller Total Money
Makeover number one bestseller Financial
Peace University you've had them and
been through all of that you'll probably
give them away seems like it's what
you've been doing but uh that's what
they're for they're for you to enjoy and
to give away thank you guys for making a
trip down what an inspiring people you
are thank you thank you very cool stuff
it's a it's the way it's supposed to be
right now absolutely
you guys did it right David and Kelly
and Addison from Virginia Richmond to be
was it Richmond
yeah there we go there we go open the
Bristol oh okay
yeah good good good all right try it
again David and Kelly and Addison from
Bristol Virginia we'll just call it that
335 000 paid off in 26 months making 275
to 350. they worked their tail ends off
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one where after whoa
yeah
Come On Dave
in a world where you can be David and
Kelly or you can be a bare minimum
Monday
uh yeah and everybody knows that your
life is going to be wonderful and
fulfilled by making mediocrity your goal
I mean come on as opposed to making
victory victory well this is it these
guys are Fighters man they got after it
a lot of work in this story a lot of
work this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
21 5 the plans of the diligent lead
surely to Advantage
but everyone who is Hasty comes surely
to Poverty General George Patton said
take calculated risk that is quite
different from being rash
amen and amen Christie is with us in
Sacramento hi Christy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thank you
sure how can we help
um so being my husband are new to the
show we just started watching it this
month and we just started baby step two
but my husband
wants to wait to pay off our student
debt by to hear what the government says
um but I want to just put it all in with
our debt snowball I was wondering if you
can give me some advice on how to talk
to him about that that's sweet it is
he still believes they're going to do it
that's so sweet
I mean
oh how much of how much student loans do
you have
together it's 14 000.
did you sign for the loans
that's what I that's what I would say to
him I'd say did we sign for these loans
let's pay them off
yeah
um here
there's a high correlation
between people's ability to build a
wealth and their belief that their
Destiny is in their hands not the
governments
very few next to know people next to
nothing next to zero of the millionaires
that we have interviewed over 30 years
got there believing that the government
was going to be a blessing to them they
didn't wait on the government to provide
Prosperity
um instead they left the cave killed
something and Drug it home and made
their own way they got the machete out
and went through the jungle
and so
um
to the extent that
anyone your husband you me believes that
the government is our source of
prosperity it slows down our energy
level to go into the marketplace and win
on our own of our own dignity and our
own energy
and that's the real tragedy of
the uh of the Biden Administration
dangling this carrot because most of us
know that they're not ever really going
to do it
it's not going to happen it's been a
political Ploy from the start I don't
believe it's going to happen it may
happen but I'll I'll have to be on here
going I was wrong and that's happened
before I've been wrong before
um Christy but uh I um
there is something inside of you the the
type of person and it's a decision it's
not a character uh flaw it's a decision
that you can make differently the type
of person that says I'm going to make my
own way in this world the type of person
that says I signed for those loans I
have an Integrity issue with not paying
back money I owe when I'm able to
and I'm capable of it uh those type
those two things that are decisions in
your character are leading indicators
for your long-term ability to build
wealth and so I would ask
um anyone out there including uh you
guys Christian I appreciate the call I'm
not picking on your husband I'm not
saying he's a bad guy uh I'm just saying
he's naive number one it's probably not
going to happen in my opinion uh number
two I would adopt the character
qualities of integrity and of agency of
the agency meaning the sense of I
control my own destiny I'm not waiting
on provision from any Administration
I'm old Christy I mean I'm 62 years old
and I've lived through in my adult life
several several presidents who uh of
both parties who promised me Prosperity
so far none of them have provided it
not one and they won't every single
thing that has happened to Sharon and I
that's positive is due to God's
blessings and due to other people that
have helped us and due to our hard work
and Ingenuity and our refusal to quit
I agree you know you said a lot of
people you said you're not going to
reach Prosperity working on waiting on
the government and I think that more
than that I think there's some folks
that might feel like well this is my way
my ticket in I just feel like a lot of
people feel like the government owes
them something and they're sitting
around waiting and I'm not saying this
the case with Christy I don't know but a
lot of people feel like I'm entitled to
this the government owes me something
and and by God I'm gonna get what they
owe me and I just I have a hard time
with that I just it I'm over here and I
get angry Dave I'm not gonna lie I get
frustrated because I'm like there's no
such thing as a free lunch like this
this quote unquote forgiveness like
folks are paying for this and and folks
who've already paid off their student
loans are gonna if it if it goes through
I don't think it will but if it did
folks that paid off their loans are
gonna pay for it folks that can't afford
you know
it's getting it'll be spread around
that just paid off uh two hundred
thousand dollars worth of their student
loans
are now going to have to pay off yeah
and here's the thing most of the people
that are getting this forgiveness I mean
we know what the the income uh bracket
was you can just afford to pay off your
loans just
to pay off your loans there's dignity
and in doing work and paying your own
bills I just gotta say that Dave because
it it frustrates me when you can pay
your own bills that's called a blessing
when you can go through life and you
have the money because you've gone to
school or you've done whatever and and
you can pay your bill just pay them just
pay them you're gonna feel great it
you're gonna feel great about yourself
yeah not sitting around waiting for the
government and again Christy I want you
to hear loud and clear we appreciate you
being a new listener and we're not it's
not you Christian and we're not picking
on your husband I'm not saying your
husband's a bad guy but you said what do
we tell him I I would challenge him as
an old guy to say I have
walking around experience proof and I've
got actual data from the larger study of
millionaires ever done and none of those
millionaires said someone else
did this
um and unless they give credit to God
but I mean they they all here's what's
interesting when we ask them uh you who
you are who is responsible for your
wealth
97 of them said we did this and and when
we said Can can it be done again
97 said it could be done again when we
interview the public that are not
millionaires only 69 percent said it can
be done wow and so what what you believe
about life affects your actions and your
actions create your Harvest your results
and so if you plant poison in fertile
soil you will grow Nightshade poison
which is a poison poisonous plant in the
same abundance that you can grow wheat
or corn in the same soil so what you sow
so shall ye reap what you pour into your
life your your belief when you put the
seed in the ground is your belief your
Harvest comes because you took action on
your belief yes and a hundred percent of
the time we all take actions on our
beliefs and so you have to be very
careful about your okay the action is
I'm going to wait on the government what
does that mean your belief is
it means that you don't think you can do
it on your own it means you think the
government is your best provision yeah
and that that is a that is a scary
belief because now we're talking about
socialism
well yeah on the political side you know
Karl Marx never made any millionaires
except him
that's what it comes down to under
communism there is an elite few that are
millionaires and they're all the people
that took it from everyone else none of
them were producers under capitalism The
Producers end up with things so all of
this to say Christian again this is just
us going off now just in general not
again not on your particular answer and
again I don't want you to take this as
condemnation like your husband's a bad
guy because we really don't think he's a
bad guy there's a lot of good people
that think this but what I would all
challenge all of you to think this is be
careful about what actions you endorse
because that speaks very loudly what
your beliefs are and it's going to tell
you what your Harvest is going to be
because what you plant a hundred percent
of the time is what comes out of the
ground 100 100 of what you plan in your
life comes up in your life a hundred
percent of it good and bad and ugly so
hey good show today good show well done
Austin Ben James Zach Andrew and Kelly
Kelly's in the booth today can't call
him the booth dudes today Booth dudes
and one gal that puts a sour in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]